hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're delving into the realm of unused
characters elusive figures that were
mentioned by Rolling but never made an
appearance in any officially released
material whether it be books or films
well we have been enthralled by the
likes of Harry Hermione and Ron there
exists a treasure Trove of characters
lying dormant in the scribblings
unpublished drafts and words spoken by
JK Rowling during interviews some were
scrapped in the editing process others
lost to the ever advancing plot and the
rest just weren't quite Harry Potter
material today we'll be delving into the
sketches interviews and whispered rumors
to uncover these intriguing yet unused
characters discussing their Origins
powers and the roles they may have
played if given the chance from a lost
Weasley family member to a Hogwarts toad
ghost to a professor named Pettigrew
this list at all I've managed to piece
together 30 characters in total which
does already seem quite a lot but if I
missed any please let me know in the
comments and I'll address it in a future
video for organization's sake I'm going
to be listing them in alphabetical order
anyway I won't Babble any longer let's
Dive In
bathshita babbling Professor bathshita
babeling was a witch and a professor of
the study of ancient runes at Hogwarts
School of Witchcraft and Wizardry she
was never mentioned in any officially
released material and has only ever been
mentioned on a draft release on JK
Rowling's website
the Black Knight was an unused ghost of
Hogwarts while not much info has been
disclosed about the Black Knight it
would appear that Rowling had already
introduced enough coasts and simply
didn't have any use for him he is
mentioned in the Pottermore article
entitled Hogwarts ghosts Elsie bones was
a character and intended Order of the
Phoenix member who was kidnapped in an
early draft for the Harry Potter books
entitled the red-eyed dwarf given her
surname she is a possible relation of
Amelia bones celebrated ahead of the
Department of magical law enforcement
Susan bones Hogwarts student and Edgar
bones brother Familia and fellow Order
of the Phoenix member after Voldemort
Was Defeated during the Battle of
Hogwarts she was said to have been
returned she's mentioned on page 176 of
a history of magic
Stephen cornfoot one of the original 40
was a pure blood wizard in Harry's ear
at Hogwarts the original 40 which is
mentioned a reasonable amount in this
video is best described in Rowling's own
words two of my most prized possessions
are a pair of small notebooks which
contain my very first scribblings about
Harry Potter much of what is written in
them was never used in the series
although it is startling to come across
the odd line of dialogue that
subsequently made it verbatim to
publication in one of the books is a
list of 40 names of students in Harry's
year including Harry Ron and Hermione
all allocated houses with small symbols
beside each name depicting each boy or
girl's parentage there isn't much info
available on Stephen but we do know that
he was either in Hufflepuff or Ravenclaw
his existence was revealed by JK Rowling
on her website where she shares some of
her original Harry Potter scribblings
Gavin Entwistle another of the original
40 was a student in Ravenclaw house at
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry in Harry's year there was also
an Annabelle and whistle in one of the
video games although he never appeared
in any of the books or movies his
existence was revealed by JK Rowling on
her website where she shares some of her
original Harry Potter scribblings in
very early drafts of the books our
beloved Hermione Granger actually had a
muggle sister that we only know as Miss
Granger the reasoning for this was
unclear and because she didn't really
have any relevance to the plot JK
decided to remove her Rowling first
mentioned Miss Granger in an interview
does Hermione have any brothers or
sisters no she doesn't when I first made
up Hermione I gave her a younger sister
but she was very hard to work in the
younger sister was not supposed to go to
Hogwarts she was supposed to remain a
muggle it was a sideline that didn't
work very well and it did not have a big
place in the story Edmund Grubb was
another unused ghost at hog courts
school he lived in the Victorian era and
died in the doorway of the Great Hall at
Hogwarts Castle after ingesting
poisonous berries after his death he
returned as a ghost to haunt The Castle
sometimes stopping people from getting
into the Great Hall out of spite JK
Rowling has expressed that she rather
regrets leaving ramp out of the bugs
he's mentioned in the Pottermore article
entitled Hogwarts ghosts Megan Jones
another of the original 40 was a
Hufflepuff student in the same year as
Harry at Hogwarts it's possible that she
is related to other members of the Jones
family gwenic Jones Esther Jones Peter
Jones and Stuart Jones if that's the
case then we can reasonably unfair that
Megan was a Half-Blood her existence was
revealed by JK Rowling on her website
where she shares some of her original
Harry Potter scribblings Oakton hernshaw
also oaked in hobday was a character
that JK Rowling considered making the
defense against the dark arts professor
in Harry Potter's fifth year instead we
got Dolores Umbridge as the data
Professor his existence was revealed on
JK Rowling's website in one of her early
drafts Wayne Hopkins another of the
original 40 was a Hufflepuff student in
the same year as Harry at Hogwarts it's
possible that he's related to Carl
Hopkins which would make him a
Half-Blood his existence was revealed by
JK Rowling on her website where she
shares some of her original Harry Potter
scribblings Suli another of the original
40 was a Ravenclaw student in the same
year as Harry at Hogwarts her existence
was first revealed in Harry Potter and
me a Christmas television Special by BBC
broadcast on the 28th of December 2001.
mafalda was a long-lost Weasley family
member and the daughter of the second
cousin who's a stockbroker mentioned in
the Philosopher's Stone there's actually
a lot of info on her mafalda was the
daughter of the second cousin who's a
stockbroker mentioned in Philosopher's
Stone this stock broker had been very
rude to Mr and Mrs Weasley in the past
but now he and his muggle wife had
inconveniently produced a wedge they
came back to the Weasleys asking for
their help in introducing her to
Wizarding Society before she starts at
Hogwarts the Weasleys agreed to taking
her for part of the summer including the
Quidditch well calm but regretted this
almost immediately Mrs Weasley suspected
that my father's parents simply wanted
to get rid of her for a while because
she turns out to be the most unpleasant
child Mrs Weasley has ever met
unfortunately however mafalda had to be
removed due to a lack of planning on
Rowling's behalf the first three books
my plan never failed me but I should
have put that plot under a microscope I
wrote what I thought was half the book
and AK huge gaping hole in the middle of
the plot I missed my deadline by two
months and the whole profile of the
books got so much higher since the third
book there was an edge of external
pressure and what exactly was that
gaping hole all about I had to pull a
character there you go the Phantom
character of Harry Potter as it turns
out mafalda was the original Rita
Skeeter or at least another Rita Skeeter
type she was also very intelligent a
rival to Hermione she served the same
function that mosquito now serves Rita
was always going to be in the book but I
built her up because I needed a kind of
conduit for information outside the
school originally this girl fulfilled
this purpose mafalda was supposed to
convey certain information about the
Death Eaters to Harry Ron and Hermione
because as a nosy eavesdropping
Slytherin who likes to impress she does
not keep her mouth shut when she
overhears their sons and daughters
talking unfortunately however bright I
made her there were obvious limitations
to what 11 year old closeted at school
could discover whereas Rita Skeeter whom
I subsequently built up to fulfill my
fall dysfunction was much more flexible
her existence was revealed by JK Rowling
in an interview Roger Malone another of
the original 40 was either a Ravenclaw
or Hufflepuff student in the same year
as Harry at Hogwarts his existence was
first revealed in Harry Potter and me a
Christmas television Special by BBC
broadcast on the 28th of December 2001.
Angus and Elizabeth McKinnon were Order
of the Phoenix members that were
captured in a very early and unused
chapter entitled the red-eyed dwarf both
he and elspeth appear to have been
merged into the character of Marlene
McKinnon they are mentioned on page 176
of a history of magic
Mildred was a muggle woman who
supposedly engaged to Jacob Kowalski she
left him and handed him back her ring
after hearing that he didn't get a loan
for his Bakery Lily Moon another of the
original 40 was a student in the same
year as Harry at Hogwarts it's possible
that Lily may have been an early version
of Luna Lovegood's character her
existence was first revealed in Harry
Potter and me mopsis was originally
intended to be one of the Divination
professors at Hogwarts mopsis was the
name of a famous seer in Greek mythology
which seems fitting he has only ever
been mentioned on a draft released on
Rowling's website mopsy the dog lover
was a highly eccentric dog-loving old
wedge who lived on the edge of hogsmeade
during fourth year she looked after
Sirius whilst he was in his dog form
thinking he was astray she was cut
because she added nothing to the plot
although never explicitly stated it's
highly likely that mopsy the dog lover
and mopsy fleibert the author of animal
ghost of Britain are the same same
individual Enid Pettigrew was the name
of a possible defense against the dark
arts or divination Professor that didn't
make the she would have been
installed as data professor in Harry's
fourth sixth or seventh year or as
divination professor in Harry's third
year it's likely that this character
would have been related to Peter
Pettigrew AKA wormtale her existence was
revealed by JK Rowling on her website
where she shares some of her original
Harry Potter scribblings purities was a
servant of Voldemort who was intended to
meet Sirius Black in front of The
Potter's House he is mentioned in an
interview by Rowling other drafts
included a character by the name of
purities whose name means Fool's Gold he
was a servant of Voldemort and was
meeting Sirius in front of The Potter's
House purities too had to be discarded
though I quite liked him as a character
he was a Dandy and wore white silk
gloves which I thought might stain
artistically with blood from time to
time Argo purities was a wizard
Alchemist and the author of alchemy
Ancient Art and Science he's mentioned
in an early draft of the Philosopher's
Stone so this Flamel bloke found the
stone said Ron no he made it said Harry
he was an alchemist which means someone
who turns base Metals into gold said
Hermione she had that old proving I know
more than everyone else look on her face
the other two noticed of course I read
about this in alchemy Ancient Art and
Science by Argo purities I missed that
one myself muttered Ron
Oliver Rivers another of the original 40
was either of a Hufflepuff or Ravenclaw
student in the same year as Harry at
Hogwarts his existence was first
revealed in Harry Potter and me Sophie
Roper another of the original 40 was
either a Hufflepuff Gryffindor or
Slytherin student in the same year as
Harry at Hogwarts her existence was
first revealed in Harry Potter and May
runcorn was a Hogwarts student in
Harry's ear and possible relation to
Albert runcorn a Ministry worker that
Harry impersonated
runcorn's surname is visible on the
small portion of the second page of JK
Rowling's student list shown on the BBC
Christmas television special Harry
Potter and me
Myla Sylvanas was a potential defense
against the dark arts professor in
Harry's fifth year at Hogwarts the name
Sylvanas was later reappropriated as the
given name of Sylvanas kettleburn
professor of care of magical creatures
Sally Smith another of the original 40
was either a Hufflepuff Gryffindor or
Slytherin student in the same year as
Harry at Hogwarts on Pottermore Rowling
revealed that the character's given name
was originally Georgina but that this
was crossed out and replaced with Sally
her existence was first revealed in
Harry Potter and me Mr Thomas was a
wizard and the biological father of Dean
Thomas during the first Wizarding War Mr
Thomas abandoned his muggle wife and
young Dean in an effort to protect them
from the Death Eaters he was soon after
murdered by the Death Eaters when he
refused to join their cause his
existence was revealed by JK Rowling on
her website where she shares some of her
original Harry Potter scribblings
the toad was an unused animal ghost of
Hogwarts School who was known for
leaving ectoplasm all over the Hogwarts
classrooms the toad is mentioned in the
Pottermore article entitled Hogwarts
ghosts
the trocar was a vampire professor at
Hogwarts that was cut by Rolling looking
back through my earliest notebooks
however I found that on my very earliest
list of staff there was a subjectless
vampire teacher I'd forgotten called
trocar a trocar is a sharply pointed
shaft inserted into arteries or cavities
to extract bodily fluids so I think it's
a rather good name for a vampire
evidently I did not think much of him as
a character though because he disappears
fairly early on in my notes for a long
time there was a persistent fan rumor
that Snape might be a vampire while it
is true that he has an unhealthy power
and is sometimes described as looking
like a large bat in his long black cloak
he never actually turns into a bat we
meet him outside the castle by daylight
and no corpses with puncture marks in
their necks ever turn up at Hogwarts in
short Snape is not a revamped trocar he
is first mentioned in an interview by JK
Rowling as we reach the end of our
journey through the depths of JK
Rowling's early dry interviews and
scribbles I find myself absolutely
intrigued by the sheer number of unused
characters that lay hidden beneath the
surface of Harry Potter while the
information about these characters may
be limited we're always free to start
using our imaginations and it's fun to
take what little we have and embark on
our own Adventures weaving tales and
constructing vibrant backstories for
some of these omitted individuals as JK
Rowling once said whether you come back
by Page or by the big screen Hogwarts
will always be there to welcome you home
and indeed it is comforting to know that
the Enchantment of the Wizarding World
extends far beyond what was officially
released that's it for today if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live